Wenn du einen Ball um eine Achse drehst und dann um eine andere, ist das nicht dasselbe wie die zwei Drehungen in umgekehrter Reihenfolge auszuführen.
Heute bei Qiskit in der Classroom werden wir sehen, was dieser Ball mit Quantencomputern und einem der berühmtesten
Prinzipien der Quantenmechanik zu tun hat — der Unschärfe-
relation. Willkommen bei Qiskit in der Classroom, einer Videoserie, in der wir ein fundamentales Konzept aufschlüsseln, dem du
in einem Kurs zum Thema Quantum Computing begegnen könntest. Jedes Video wird von einem interaktiven Modul begleitet, das in der
Beschreibung verlinkt ist, also schau da unbedingt rein. Heute sprechen wir über die Heisenbergsche Unschärferelation. Wenn
du schon davon gehört hast, kennst du vielleicht auch den alten Witz über Heisenberg: Eines Tages wurde er beim Fahren angehalten und der Polizist fragte ihn: Wissen
Sie, wie schnell Sie gefahren sind? Heisenberg antwortete: Nein, aber ich weiß genau, wo ich bin. Das ist im Grunde
die Heisenbergsche Unschärferelation in einer Nussschale: Du kannst nicht gleichzeitig die Position und den Impuls eines Teilchens
mit perfekter Genauigkeit kennen. Sie wird oft so geschrieben: Delta x mal Delta p ist größer als
oder gleich h/2, wobei Delta X und Delta P die
Unschärfen in Position und Impuls sind und h eine winzige Fundamentalkonstante der Quantenmechanik ist.
Heisenberg kam 1927 auf diese Ungleichung, als er sich vorstellte, wie man die Position eines Elektrons messen könnte. Wenn
du ein Photon von ihm abprallen lässt, um zu sehen, wo es ist, würde dieses Photon unweigerlich das Elektron anstoßen und seinen
Impuls stören. Das ist nicht nur eine Aussage darüber, dass Messungen ein System stören — es sagt uns, dass es fundamentale
Grenzen gibt, wie viel wir über die Natur erfahren können. Das ist ein Beispiel für ein breiteres Prinzip namens Komplementarität, das
besagt, dass bestimmte Aspekte der Natur miteinander unvereinbar sind und nicht gleichzeitig beobachtet werden
können. Zum Beispiel verhalten sich Quantenobjekte manchmal wie Teilchen und manchmal wie Wellen,
aber du kannst nicht beide Verhaltensweisen gleichzeitig beobachten. Heisenbergs Positions-Impuls-Relation deckte nur eine von
vielen Mengen komplementärer Eigenschaften ab. Diese inhärente Unschärfe hat damit zu tun, wie wir Eigenschaften wie
Position und Impuls in der Quantenmechanik betrachten. Anstatt X und P als Variablen oder intrinsische Eigenschaften zu betrachten,
die jedes Teilchen besitzt, sind Position und Impuls in der Quantenmechanik Operatoren. Sie sind keine Eigenschaften eines
Systems, sondern Dinge, die man mit einem System tun kann. Etwas über die Position eines Teilchens zu erfahren, erfordert jetzt, eine
Operation an diesem System durchzuführen und eine Messung vorzunehmen. Diese Operation könnte das Ergebnis anderer nachfolgender
Operationen beeinflussen. Als Analogie denke an ein Stück trockenes Holz. Es hat viele Eigenschaften wie seine
Position, Größe, Form. Es hat auch die Eigenschaft, brennbar und schwimmfähig im Wasser zu sein. Wenn dieses Holz ein
Quantenobjekt wäre, wären das keine Eigenschaften, die du einfach a priori kennen könntest. Stattdessen sagen wir, es sind
Observable — Dinge, die du über das System erfahren kannst, wenn du eine Operation daran durchführst. Du müsstest also den Brennbarkeits-
oder Schwimmfähigkeits-Operator anwenden, was bedeuten würde, tatsächlich zu versuchen, das Holz zu verbrennen oder es ins
Wasser zu legen, um zu sehen, ob es schwimmt. Nun hängt das Ergebnis jedes dieser Operatoren von der Reihenfolge ab, in der du sie anwendest. Wenn
du zuerst die Brennbarkeit testest, verbrennt das Holz zu Asche und du kannst nicht mehr testen, ob es schwimmt. Aber wenn du
zuerst die Schwimmfähigkeit testest, ist es zu nass zum Brennen. Wir sagen, dass die Brennbarkeits- und
Schwimmfähigkeits-Operatoren nicht kommutieren — die Reihenfolge der Operationen ist wichtig. Das führt zu einer fundamentalen
Grenze, wie gut diese beiden Observablen über das Stück Holz bekannt sein können, da wir nicht sicher sagen können, ob es
brennbar oder schwimmfähig ist, ohne den Kontext dieser Messung zu kennen. Natürlich könntest du bei einem echten Stück Holz
es in zwei Hälften schneiden und beide Eigenschaften gleichzeitig testen, aber mit einem Quantenteilchen geht so etwas nicht. Diese
Analogie mit Holz ist eben nur eine Analogie. Unschärfe ist eine einzigartig quantenmechanische Sache. X und P kommutieren auch nicht,
und diese Eigenschaft der Nicht-Kommutativität führt zur Heisenbergschen Unschärferelation. Allgemein haben zwei beliebige Operatoren,
die nicht kommutieren, ihre eigene Unschärferelation. Die allgemeine Form der Unschärferelation kann
so geschrieben werden: Delta a mal Delta
B ist größer als oder gleich
1/2 mal dem Betrag von A und B, wobei
diese Klammer der sogenannte
Kommutator ist, und das ist gleich der Differenz zwischen zuerst A dann
B anzuwenden und zuerst B dann A anzuwenden. Diese spitzen Klammern
hier bedeuten, dass du den sogenannten Erwartungswert des Inhalts nimmst. Im Grunde, wenn du die gleiche
Messung viele, viele Male durchführst, ist der Erwartungswert der Durchschnittswert aller dieser Messungen. Heute werden wir
diese Unschärferelation tatsächlich auf einem IBM Quantencomputer testen und verifizieren. Wir betrachten drei verschiedene
Observable eines Qubits, zeigen, dass ihre Operatoren nicht kommutieren, und können dann beweisen, dass die
Unschärferelation für diese Qubit-Observablen gilt. Zunächst ein kurzer Exkurs über eine hilfreiche Art, den Quanten-
Zustand eines Qubits zu visualisieren. Er kann als Vektor dargestellt werden, der auf einen Punkt auf einer Kugel zeigt, der sogenannten Bloch-Kugel. Ich habe das
in einem früheren Video behandelt, das in der Beschreibung verlinkt ist, aber ich gebe dir hier auch eine kurze Zusammenfassung. Hier ist die
Bloch-Kugel. Jeder Vektor wird durch zwei Winkel parametrisiert, Theta und Phi.
Der Zustand Null ist am Nordpol und der Zustand Eins am Südpol, und eine gleiche Superposition von 0 und 1 liegt
irgendwo am Äquator, wobei Phi gleich der relativen Phase zwischen den beiden Teilen der
Superposition ist. Dieser Zustand hier wäre also gleich
1/√2 mal 0 + e hoch i Phi mal 1, wobei i diese
Phase ist. Wenn wir eine Observable des Qubits messen, ist das Ergebnis immer eine von zwei Möglichkeiten, die den beiden
möglichen Zuständen des Qubits entsprechen. Für das Experiment, das wir gleich durchführen, betrachten wir drei Observable und
ihre entsprechenden Operatoren X, Y und Z. Wenn du eine dieser Observablen misst, erhältst du entweder plus eins oder
minus eins, mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit für jedes, die vom Winkel zwischen dem Vektor des Qubits auf der Bloch-Kugel und
der Messachse abhängt. Wie du dir vielleicht denkst, misst Z entlang der Z-Achse, X entlang X
und Y entlang Y. Denk daran, dass wir über Observable sprechen, weil wir bei einem Quanten-
System nicht mehr einfach Dinge über das System wissen können, ohne sie zu messen.
Und jede Observable hat eine entsprechende Operation, weil Messungen Operationen erfordern. Es mag nicht offensichtlich sein, aber
es stellt sich heraus, dass die Operationen, also die Operatoren, die jeder dieser Observablen X, Y und Z entsprechen,
Drehungen um Pi um ihre jeweiligen Achsen sind. Also ist X eine Drehung um X, Y
um Y und Z um Z. Um also zu sehen, ob diese Operatoren kommutieren oder nicht, können wir prüfen, ob Drehungen
auf einer Kugel kommutieren. Wenn ja, gilt die Unschärferelation nicht, und wir könnten X, Y und Z eines Qubits
mit perfekter Genauigkeit kennen. Wenn sie nicht kommutieren, können wir eine neue Unschärferelation für das Qubit finden. Beobachte
den Punkt auf diesem Ball, wenn ich zuerst um X und dann um Y drehe. Er landet
hier. Jetzt versuchen wir es in umgekehrter Reihenfolge. Also drehe ich zuerst um Y und
dann um X. Er landet hier drüben. Also kommutieren sie definitiv nicht. Das bedeutet,
wir können die genauen X-, Y- und Z-Werte eines Qubits nicht gleichzeitig kennen — wir haben eine
Unschärferelation. Wir überspringen die Details hier, aber wir erhalten drei verschiedene Unschärfe-
relationen. Also haben wir: Delta X mal Delta Y
ist größer als oder gleich dem Betrag von Z. Delta Y mal Delta Z ist größer als oder
gleich dem Betrag von X. Und Delta Z mal Delta X ist größer als oder gleich dem
Betrag von Y. Also ist das Produkt von zwei beliebigen dieser Unschärfen immer größer als oder
gleich dem Erwartungswert der dritten Observablen. Lass uns Qiskit verwenden, um zu sehen, was
passiert, wenn wir versuchen, sowohl Z als auch X des Zustands Null zu messen. Z zu messen ist einfach — es ist die sogenannte Standardbasis
des Quantencomputers. Messungen sind standardmäßig immer entlang Z. Aber um X zu messen, müssen wir etwas durchführen, das
Basiswechsel genannt wird — im Grunde die Bloch-Kugel so drehen, dass X jetzt nach oben zeigt, wo vorher Z war. Dafür
verwenden wir ein Hadamard-Gate. Also sieht der vollständige Quanten-Circuit so aus: Wir messen in Z, wenden das Hadamard
an und messen dann in X. Wenn wir das Qiskit-Primitive Sampler verwenden, um dieses Experiment viele Male durchzuführen,
erhalten wir ein Histogramm der Messergebnisse, das für die Z-
Messung so aussieht und für die Messung in X so. Wie du sehen kannst, haben wir das
Qubit entlang Z mit ziemlich genau 100% Sicherheit im Null-Zustand gemessen, aber
entlang X wussten wir im Grunde nichts über den Qubit-Zustand. Es wurde mit gleicher
Wahrscheinlichkeit als Null oder Eins gemessen, was bedeutet, dass unsere Unschärfe in X so groß wie möglich war. Das gibt uns
ein Gefühl für diesen Kompromiss der Unschärfen, aber wir können es auf unserem Quantencomputer noch besser machen. Wir können ein
Qiskit-Primitive namens Estimator verwenden, um die Erwartungswerte unserer Observablen X, Y und Z und die
Unschärfe in jedem zu finden. Versuchen wir es für den Zustand, der in die Plus-X-Richtung auf der Bloch-Kugel zeigt. Wir verwenden den Estimator,
um die Unschärfen in X und Z für diesen Zustand und den Erwartungswert von
Y zu berechnen. Mit diesem Zustand erhalten wir dieses Ergebnis von Qiskit. Wenn wir das Produkt der beiden
Unschärfen in X und Y nehmen, sehen wir, dass es wie erwartet größer ist als der absolute
Wert des Erwartungswerts von Y. Aber das war nur für einen bestimmten Zustand. Wir wollen sicherstellen, dass diese Ungleichung
für alle Qubit-Zustände gilt. Also verwenden wir den Estimator erneut, aber diesmal bitten wir ihn, die Werte eines
Parameters durchzuscannen und die Erwartungswerte bei jedem einzelnen Parameterwert zu finden. Hier ist der Parameter, den wir
scannen wollen, der Winkel Theta auf der Bloch-Kugel, sodass wir die Ungleichung für alle Qubit-Zustände prüfen, die auf
diesem Bogen liegen, der die XZ-Ebene schneidet. Wenn wir das tun, erhalten wir einen Plot als Funktion des Winkels Theta. Die rote
Kurve ist das Produkt der beiden Unschärfen und die orangefarbene Kurve ist der Erwartungswert von Y. Wie erwartet
ist das Produkt der Unschärfen in X und Z viel höher als der Erwartungswert von Y. Aber das war
nicht allzu schwer, die Ungleichung zu erfüllen, weil der Erwartungswert von Y so niedrig war — er war für alle Zustände auf
diesem Bogen null. Machen wir einen ähnlichen Scan durch die Theta-Werte, aber anstatt in der XZ-Ebene zu scannen, setzen wir Phi gleich Pi/
4, sodass wir die Qubit-Zustände betrachten, die auf einem anderen Bogen auf der Kugel liegen. Hier sehen wir, dass die Ungleichung
etwas mehr gefordert wird, da die orangefarbene und die rote Kurve näher beieinander liegen, aber die rote ist immer über der orangefarbenen,
und die Unschärferelation gilt immer noch. Wir haben noch nicht alle Zustände überprüft, aber hoffentlich bekommst du langsam
die Idee. Es gibt eine fundamentale Nicht-Wissbarkeit über zwei beliebige komplementäre Aspekte eines Quanten-
Systems, einschließlich dieses Qubits, das wir verwendet haben. Die Unschärferelation zwingt uns, der Tatsache ins Auge zu sehen, dass egal
wie sehr wir es versuchen, egal wie clever unsere Messungen sind, wir werden nie alles mit perfekter Genauigkeit wissen.
Es gibt wirklich kein Entkommen. Wenn du mir nicht glaubst, oder auch wenn doch, fordere ich dich heraus: Schau dir das Modul an,
das in der Beschreibung verlinkt ist, und versuche, die Unschärferelation zu schlagen. Danke fürs Zuschauen, und bis zum nächsten Mal.